ich will ihnen einmal zeigen wir stefan
mielchen zu sagen hat auch ein zuschauer
von bild herr lauterbach haben sie eine
idee wie lange der ganze scheiß noch
dauert
da ist eine sehr kurze frage und die
schnelle antwort ist die also ich glaube
nicht dass die letzte variante die
omikron variante ist das heißt das wird
nicht zu ende sein mit omega wer meint
ja die maßnahmen da so die maßnahmen die
ich dachte er gesagt hat ich glaube der
scheiß war er bezogen auf masten pflicht
zweig zweig plus all diese dinge die
immer noch da sind und in anderen
ländern wechselt er hat das also ehrlich
gesagt also die frage also ich bin ich
bereit das was wir hier tun
um menschenleben zu retten und schwerer
krankheit zu verhindern
und also long kopie zu verhindern und
unsere gesellschaft also vor schwersten
lang fast folgen zu schützen ich bin
nicht bereit das also also als scheiß zu
diskutieren ich glaube dass wir vor
deutlich vor ostern lockern werden davon
bin ich fest überzeugt aber ich arbeite
einfach gerne
mit wissenschaftlichen daten und wir
haben nicht mal was heißt deutlich vor
ostern herr lauterbach
wenn es so ist wir haben ja gesagt mitte
januar wer gesagt mit der februar ist
die der höhepunkt der welle und dann
gehen die fallzahlen deutlich runter
wenn das tatsächlich klappt wenn wir
hinkommen sehen die fallzahlen gehen
runter und es ist gelungen
also einen großen teil der bevölkerung
zu schützen vor schwerer krankheit oder
foto das man dann in die lockerungen
über geht das ganz klar aber also
erstens muss man erst mal darf das fell
des bären nicht
verteilen bevor er erschossen ist und
wie lockerung am 16 dann sind wir
wahrscheinlich noch mit da war ja aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wir über
lockerungen diskutieren ob das
tatsächlich zu lockerungen kommt das
hängt davon ab wo wir dann steht und
wenn wir im herbst dann tatsächlich eine
impfpflicht bekämen dann glaube ich ist
der spuk vorbei wir malen immer wieder
aus wie dramatisch alles ist haben sie
auf aber das sei twitter twittern sie
jeden tag neue studien schlimm dass wir
noch schlimmer aber das ganz dramatisch
nein ist es nicht also
es stehen da einfach schlicht so gar
nicht das kann ich ja auch nicht stehen
lassen sollte das verfestigt sich ja das
sind also sagen wir das ist mir nicht zu
nahe treten aber das ist eigentlich
nichts anderes als also was sie jetzt
vorgetragen haben das wäre alles also
dramatisch und soweit vortage das
geschwurbel ich bin orientiere mich im
großen und ganzen an dem modell des
robert-koch-instituts wenn meier der
top-mann und wir fahren gezielt mit
diesem modell schon seit der zweiten
januarwoche fahren wir die maßnahmen und
das hat im großen und ganzen auch
geklappt wir versuchen daher maßvoll
reinzugehen und wenn ich mich auch wohl
eher nicht maßvoll wenn weltweit wie die
strengsten maßnahmen haben wenn um uns
herum die maßnahmen fallen wenn alle auf
machen und sie weiter sagen nein es
bleibt so wir haben also maßnahmen die
im verhältnis zu den maßnahmen die
richtige harte drakonischen maßnahmen
gewesen sind beispielsweise hatte
lockdown maßnahmen haben wir die haben
wir selbst in der ersten welle nicht
ergriffen also mann david sind wir in
java weitere jahre oder weil er laut und
manchmal nicht mehr über die
vergangenheit hin herr wieder und sie da
denkt man ja eigentlich sie telefonieren
relativ viel sie haben wir auch bei der
tag schreiben sms emails was auch immer
und bei so einer entscheidenden frage
können sich viele eben nicht vorstellen
dass er wieder da wirklich in
irgendeiner form einfach allein
gehandelt haben soll ja dass das oft
dass er diesen beschluss also
auf die homepage gestellt hat und somit
wurde der ja quasi
automatisch über die verweisung zurecht
das wusste ich nicht das wird auch nicht
mehr vorkommen als dass ich damit nicht
zufrieden gewesen bin was haben sie an
wieder gesagt dass wir haben uns auf
jeden fall ausgesprochen aber die was
klar ist was was viel wichtiger ist ich
habe das fahren geändert sie stehen so
hinwiler viele würden sich fragen wenn
man so informiert und wenn das so stimmt
was sie sagen warum ist er dann noch im
amt er hat also zwei jahre lang eine
sehr wichtige gute arbeit gemacht und
genießt weiter man vertrauen so einfach
ist das aber ich trotzdem trotzdem also
sage ich also das hier war nicht in
ordnung das wird sich auch nicht
wiederholen werden wir jetzt eine
impfpflicht also machen dann muss es
auch richtiges handwerk sein dass wir
das problem erledigen werden wir an
pflicht machen ich sage mal ab
50 oder eine pflicht für jeden zweiten
oder was auch immer sagen haben wir
nachher eine riesen debatte um die
impfpflicht gehabt und das problem ist
noch immer nicht gelöst und daher denke
ich einmal sollten wir dann auch also
ein sauberes handwerk ablehnen ablegen
und in der gruppe der 18 bis 50 jährigen
sind so viele die auch schwer erkranken
können die muss ich ja auch schützen von
daher ist das aus meiner sicht noch
immer der plausibelste also vorschlag